bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag qui
n'a jamais envisagé de changer d'emploi
la reconversion professionnelle permet
une deuxième vie un deuxième souffle
nous avons rencontré virginie qui a
sauté le pas lu vs q la cité des métiers
deux acteurs du terrain répondront à nos
questions l'école paul school nous
expliquera quels sont les nouveaux
métiers du numérique
et puis deux élus du territoire nous
renseigneront sur les possibilités
offertes sur saint quentin en yvelines
c'est parti
[Musique]
vous avez déjà songé à vous reconvertir
professionnellement
non pour quelle raison ce que je suis
satisfait dans mon métier ça sera à
recommencer je retrouve chose j'ai des
idées plus tard dans d'ici cinq ans de
changer de métier
ça va faire du bien quand même parce
qu'il faut avoir des expériences dans
tout jeu j'aurais voulu faire un travail
donné alors ça dit finalement ça a été
beaucoup mieux pour moi c'est ma vie en
fait il faut pas penser quand
aujourd'hui rentré dans la société on va
rester jusqu'à la retraite
ça existe
d'autres ou déjà sauté le pas direction
le sésame le campus des services de
l'automobile et de la mobilité à
guyancourt
j'étais adjoint territorial qui se
passait très bien mais j'avais envie de
changer tout simplement de voix comme
gta triplettes et cyclistes je ne sais
pas si on l'a depuis tout petit après sa
formation christian est devenu
mécanicien cycle vanessa a également
tourné la page de ses années
d'assistantes maternelles elle s'est
orientée vers la moto
on m'aurait dit à 1 en surtemps à
l'école même pour faire autre chose que
j'aurais bien mais j'aurais jamais de la
vie je vais retourner à l'école
je m'accroche parce que enfin vraiment
je suis motivé et j'ai envie d'avoir ce
c ap j'ai envie de faire carrière à là
dedans tout comme virginie
à la base cette habitante de plaisir à
une formation en comptabilité et gestion
auparavant je travaillais dans une
entreprise
de téléphonie mobile ça faisait 15 ans
que j'y étais et au bout de quinze ans
je
me reconnaissais plus vraiment dans
l'entreprise dans les enjeux dans les
objectifs
virginie va profiter d'un plan de
départs au sein de son entreprise pour
sauter le pas et effectuer un bilan de
compétences ce bilan de compétences en
fait a montré alors déjà marre motivé
m'a redonné confiance en moi il a appuyé
un certain nombre de
une qualité que je pouvais
à voir et surtout l'art déterminé mon
profil financé par son ex employeur dans
le cadre du plan de départs volontaires
elle se lance dans une licence
professionnelle à l'iut descartes à
paris
mais que faire de cette licence pour
avoir un poste qui m'intéresserait aux
niveaux d'émissions c'était plus
intéressant pour moi de poursuivre j'ai
trouvé un master ici à lui est ce qu cet
ancien élève de lever ce qu est retourné
sur les bancs de la fac
vingt ans après dossier de financement
dossier de candidature virginie intègre
un master 1 puis un master 2 oui c'est
tout à fait possible si tonte et qu'on
s'en donne les moyens
alors aujourd'hui je suis chef de projet
dans une association située aux mureaux
et qui travaille sur le développement
durable
je me sens très bien épanouie valoriser
je sais pourquoi je me lève le matin
l'université de versailles saint quentin
offre un peu plus de 200 formations de
la licence jusqu'au master en passant
par des titres d'ingénieur et des déités
toutes sont ouvertes à la reconversion
professionnelle chaque année nous avons
deux mille stagiaires on appelle ça des
stagiaires dont des personnes qui
viennent reprendre leurs études à
l'université
donc soit sur des programmes longs
diplôme en soit sur des programmes plus
cours de spécialisation management
gestion droit sciences politiques
les formations sont ouvertes pour des
personnes déjà en poste qui souhaitent
compléter leur compétence ou changer de
métier demandeurs d'emploi indépendants
salariés du public ou du privé se
forment à l'université mais il ya des
formations qui sont faites en accord
avec son service rh donc l'entreprise
constate qu'il ya un besoin en
compétences qui manquent
et donc il va envoyer un certain nombre
de personnes de collaborateurs en
formation soit sur les formations qui
existent soit l'entreprise peut même
concevoir avec l'université une
formation qui va répondre précisément à
ses besoins d'autres en accord avec
leurs entreprises obtiennent un congé
pour se former durant un an ou deux et
apprendre un nouveau métier ou monter en
compétences même sans bac l'université
c'est possible les cours du soir
permettent d'obtenir un diplôme
équivalent le diplôme d'accès aux études
universitaires
autre possibilité pour obtenir un
diplôme
la validation des acquis de l'expérience
une expérience forgée par des années
passées en entreprise
le candidat monte un dossier passe
devant un jury il peut obtenir une
licence ou un master une vraie
reconnaissance des compétences
professionnelles qui permet au salarié
d'évoluer dans leur carrière et
d'obtenir des postes à plus grande
responsabilité
[Musique]
lu vs qu est aussi la seule université
du territoire à avoir un centre de bilan
de compétences intégrer le territoire
regorge de partenaires vers lesquels se
tourner en cas de reconversion
professionnelle la cité des métiers
attrapé l'un d'eux comment ça marche
réponse avec christiane butte
[Musique]
et
la plupart du temps ce sont des adultes
qui arrive en milieu de parcours
professionnels qui font une pause qui
veulent réfléchir qu'ils font un point
soit qu'ils sont insatisfaits de leur
situation actuelle soit parce qu'ils ont
une impossibilité de d'exercer leur
métier parce que il ya des contraintes
médicales qui sont apparus retrouver du
sens donc s'il travaille au milieu de
parcours nécessite une vraie réflexion
une reconversion réussie je dirais que
c'est une reconversion pour laquelle on
a pris le temps pourquoi entamé cette
démarche et ben je veux prendre du temps
pour éviter d'en perdre
on encourage vraiment les personnes à se
poser pour mener une réflexion qui soit
pertinente et qui qui puisse déboucher
sur une réelle activité professionnelle
ici différents ateliers sont proposés
pour rebondir après un échec pour
s'appuyer sur ses propres ressources et
son potentiel pour effectuer un bilan de
compétences ou pour s'orienter vers une
validation des acquis de l'expérience
une fois tous les deux mois la cité des
métiers accueille aussi le forum santé
et emploi de la cramif pour mener les
personnes qui sortent d'arrêt maladie
vers un nouveau projet
les choix qu'on fait aujourd'hui ils
sont valables peut-être pour je ne sais
pas 5 8 ans les années qui viennent mais
les choses bougent tellement vite que on
est tous à mener
à croiser d'autres chemins pour qu'une
reconversion fonctionne une enquête
métier est indispensable les métiers du
numérique notamment offrent de vrais
débouchés
nous sommes allés dans les locaux de pop
foule installée depuis peu à elancourt
le centre de formation ouvrira ses
portes au public le 14 octobre en même
temps que comment sont les premières
formations métiers du numérique un
secteur qui a le vent en poupe
mais peut-on tous devenir informaticien
on a besoin d'un esprit logique on a
besoin de personnes qui sont à l'aise
avec les outils numériques mais de
manière générale et on a besoin de
personnes qui vont avoir une grande
autonomie puisque en fait comme les
technologies deviennent obsolètes au
bout de quelques années quand on rentre
dans ces professions on va se former
toute sa vie par soi-même en octobre
prochain deux formations seront
proposées par pop school data sécurité
elle peur pour une formation d'assistant
de sécurisation des données
un certificat médical à coeur
le pirate éthique très recherchée au
milieu professionnel sera délivré à
l'issue du stage
la deuxième formation est celle de
fabricants d'objets connectés haïti
maker débouchera sur un titre
professionnel de technicien de test et
de prototypes profil manuel et
techniques recommandées
aucun pré requis de niveau n'est exigée
en dehors de la motivation et la
détermination
en six mois les apprenants aurons un
niveau bac + 2 durant ces formations de
vrais projets sont d'ailleurs mises en
oeuvre les stagiaires du pop school
lillois ont mis en place un système
d'arrosage automatique d'un stade
résultats de ce sommet litres d'eau par
an d'économies v c'est ce genre de
démonstration qui aidera les entreprises
le pense à comprendre que les gens qui
sont formés chez nous sont tout à fait
opérationnel autres candidats attirer
les femmes la transformation numérique
du monde
besoins des femmes aujourd'hui plus de
la moitié des utilisateurs du numérique
sont des utilisatrices et il y a encore
80% de ceux qui font le numérique qui
sont des hommes
les entreprises ont vraiment besoin de
rééquilibrer cette chose là et donc les
opportunités pour les femmes sont
absolument extraordinaires
mesdames les portes du numérique vous
sont ouvertes l'emploi et la formation
sont une priorité sur le territoire
saint quentinois de nombreux rendez vous
auront lieu tout au long de l'année
entre les saint quentinois et les
acteurs du monde économique
nous avons rencontré deux élus en charge
de ces deux thématiques lui véhicules
estaca 3 y est le nôtre le lycée
hôtelier autant de grandes écoles qui
facilite la reconversion sur le
territoire saint quentinois
nous balayons eu un panel très très
important de pour tout ce qui concerne
la reconversion ou la formation
professionnelle puisque chacun de ces
acteurs est amené à proposer des
reconversions ou des formations
supplémentaires depuis 2010 est
l'agglomération a créé son campus
numérique afin de répondre aux besoins
des entreprises
ainsi cette école se sont installés sur
le territoire
treize formations sont aujourd'hui
proposés l'agglomération met un point
d'honneur sur tout ce qui a trait au
développement économique
il ya une demande très très importante
sur le numérique alors l'agglomération
mais un coup d'accélérateur qui va
depuis l'école du numérique c'est à dire
pour les pour les enfants même pour les
douze communes qui appartiennent à
l'agglomération mais également pour la
formation professionnelle sur notre
agglomération où il ya à peu près 130
140 mille emplois il semblerait qu'ils
aient près de 10000 postes non pourvus
ce qui est ce qui est énorme mais ce
sont des postes qui sont aussi bien dans
le numérique majorité ici mais on peut
avoir aussi des postes non pourvus sur
d'autres professions comme par exemple
tout ce qui a trait à l'hôtellerie
[Musique]
erwan le gall vous êtes délégué
communautaire en charge de l'emploi et
de l'insertion à la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin la
reconversion professionnelle aujourd'hui
c'est une réalité
ah oui c'est une réalité pour plusieurs
raisons la première parce que les gens
ont envie de changer de d'emploi de
métier et on sait que dans une carrière
on peut même changer jusqu'à avoir juste
être dix orientations tout au long de sa
vie mais de changer de métier c'est je
crois 2006 que deux fois voilà avec les
les changements et les ponts
d'intelligence artificielle et numérique
et bien évidemment des gens se prennent
en main en charge très rapidement pour
changer de métier donc lui quelque chose
qui est une évidence
on est en plein en pleine mutation de
l'emploi bien sûr et du coup l'emploi la
formation c'est quand même une priorité
sur saint quentin en yvelines
il y à quantité de deux rendez vous qui
sont mises en place
quels sont ils à nous en plaindre
rendez-vous de mis en place
d'ailleurs pour information nous avons
eu 38 rendez-vous en 2019
voilà et on n'a pas fini l'année ses
conséquences est conséquent et on a mis
surtout en place en piste pour l'emploi
enfin s qui emploie maintenant voilà qui
a un rendez-vous qui dure toute une
journée ou descendre des formations
peuvent venir
évidemment où il ya la communication
c'est pour le changement de vie par
rapport à son activité professionnelle
et puis nous avons mis également un site
en ligne ce qui emploie qui a eu l'écho
de ce groupe bel est gros événement mais
c'est surtout aussi pour les gens que ça
permet de regarder ce qui s'y passe sur
le territoire et pour information parce
que ça c'est vraiment un scoop
nous avions un objectif en septembre
donc 1er septembre à peu près de 2000
inscriptions de candidats nous en sommes
à de 7400 voilà ce qui prouve que c'est
une vraie demande un vrai besoin
on s'est pas trompé alors ça ça
nécessite aussi d'un vrai pôle de
formation notamment avec des grandes
écoles sur le territoire pour répondre
aujourd'hui aux besoins des entreprises
oui tout à fait donc nous avons des
grandes écoles vous l'avez dit nous
avons l'université nous avons mis en
place sur l'école du numérique
parce qu'il y avait des besoins sur
certains secteurs d'activité
les grandes écoles
on doit les faire vite en faire venir
d'autres sur l'université on est rentrés
encore mieux qu'avant
dans le classement de shanghai et on a
réussi à avoir une bonne place
donc oui on est attentif à tout ça la
particularité des grandes écoles c'est
lorsque les jeunes sortent avec un
diplôme
nous devons tout faire pour les garder
ici voilà ça c'est l'enjeu d'accord
alors vous parliez tout à l'heure de ce
rendez-vous au vélodrome le ski emplois
il y aura forcément eu son succès un
troisième rendez-vous en avec prochain
c'est incontournable
oui il y aura une troisième session les
services sont déjà en train de
travailler dessus j'ai donné un certain
nombre de 2 go de principe sur le thème
sur la dynamique à mettre en place voilà
d'accord très bien va le rendez vous est
pris
merci beaucoup rire selon bercy ce qui
m'agace c'est terminé vous savez
désormais tout sur la reconversion
professionnelle à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]